hello everyone a most exciting thing
just happened in the chest world but I'm
sure you already heard about it as your
follow what goes on in the chest world
the the 13 year old international master
from Germany Vincent came were just one
at the Grange HS Open tournament it's
it's a tournament that has been going on
simultaneously as the Greinke chess
classic only started a few days before
that so today was the final round and
this is a game from the final round of
this tournament so Vincent gamer 2,400
something an international master from
Germany he's 13
has the black pieces against Richard
rapport the game is extremely exciting
and the result a young Vincent achieved
in this tournament is is just
spectacular
so by winning this event he qualified to
enter the ranking chess classic next
year so winning this event this year and
next year he will face the big boys in
the Greinke chess classic and it's not
not not really a small achievement there
were almost 800 players there tons of
grandmasters and some of some of the
grandmasters were even rated above 2700
so I will show you all of the opponents
he played against but first let's check
out this game as it's a quite a
spectacular game for for the last round
of this tournament so facing an
incredibly strong opponents Richard
Report and with the black pieces robert
opens with d4 we have d5 c4 and east six
so the Queens gambit declined Knight to
c3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to g5 here we
have Bishop to e7 and I just want to
tell you a short story here when we were
when I was playing at a tournament not
at a tournament but it was a club
against Club
I went there with my chess club dodo
dodo the engine boy as you know him from
my streams he had this position with the
black pieces he played Knight to d7 his
opponent played C capture some d5 ich
after some d5 and then his opponent
played the night capture Sun d5 what's
the idea that he just won upon that of
course the knight on f6 is pinned dodo
simply played
Knight captures here and now his
opponent
that he just lost the game and here but
his opponent the thing for some fifteen
minutes before actually capturing this
pawn heater Gravatt daughter simply
played Knight captures here and now you
see the problem if you capture the Queen
simply Bishop to b4 check and white is
lost Queen d2 simply only move Bishop
captures skin captures and then King
captures Bishop on the eight black one a
piece a completely winning position but
okay in the game Bishop to e7 was played
III h6 now Bishop to h4 castles rope to
c1 Knight B to d7 these are all standard
moves for this variation C capture some
d5e captors on d5 Bishop to d3 c6 Bishop
to g3 now rook to e8 and h3 Bishop to b4
preparing Knight to e4 Knight to f3
Knight to e4 now and the bishop to f4
not allowing the night to capture the
bishop and g3
we have c5 here a report castles and now
Bishop captures on c3 bill captures on
c3 and night the b6 and here since
Knight came to b6 he no longer controls
d5 square Robert decides to go for
Knight to e5 also an idea was night to
d2 to go for some exchanges in the
center but a report does need a win to
qualify for actually winning this
tournament so he can't really afford to
go for some drawing lines Knight to e5
and now f6 giving away the knight Knight
to g4 and now C for kicking the bishop
black Bishop to be one and now h5 and
this is the first critical moment of the
game here
Robert played night to h2 what you
should have gone for is nice to h6 check
now after G captures only then played
Queen captures on h5 and here white what
would have an excellent attack as f3 is
coming so you would dislodge this Knight
from me for this will open up your
Bishop from b1 so after black starts to
organize the defense something like rook
to e7 now comes f3 Knight to g5 now h5h
for King go in the 1904
tonight 2h7 you can go g4 and white
white is definitely starting the attack
here but in the game after h5 a rapper
didn't go for a night to h6 check he
decides to give up a priest differently
he played night 2 h2 and now after a
Vincent played g5 now he decided to play
Queen captures on h5 so he decided to
give up the bishop on f4 instead of the
night
we have pawn captures on f4 and now f3
now you either move the knight or you
keep the night and or you either give up
the night remove the night and allow
Queen to h7 check vincent allows it he
plays Knight to d6 Queen to h7 check
King to f8 and now Queen to h6 check
King to e7 and Queen to g7 check and
here's a very good question for you look
at this position the king is only 7 so
what do you play here
imagine you were defending this position
is black would you go Knight to f7
making some room for your king or would
you play King to e6 a very interesting
choice in the game Vincent played ink to
e6
so going going for a walk with the King
rook F to e1 threatening to push efore
or it captures on f4 open up lines the
King is an e6 it's a perfect position to
attack rook to e7 attacking the Queen
and now Queen to g4 and not allowing the
King to escape via d7 f5 now Bishop
captures on f5 would check Knight
captures and now you not really to push
efore pin the night and threaten to open
D file this way or you go twin to g6
check followed by capturing capturing
the knight on f5 I wrap replay the queen
to g6 and this comes with check kinked
d7 moves and now Queen captures on f5
capturing the knight King to c6 and now
Queen captures on f4 so a report is
still down a whole piece but he does
have an extremely strong center here and
the king is awkwardly placed on c6 but
is there compensation for the piece
Bishop to e6 by Vincent's developing a
piece preparing to bring the rook into
the game as once you develop develop
those pieces the the extra piece will
really come in handy
efore now comes Queen to g8 Queen to h6
and now into King to c7 here King to h1
white what white can't really move the
Queen off of the H file as Bishop
captures an h3 would be will be a pretty
nice move for black so first came to h1
not allowing any ideas rook to f8 and
now rook to e2 protecting protecting the
Jeep one and may be preparing to double
up rooks and the B file if Vincent
allows it rope to h7 and now the screen
no longer has really anywhere to go only
square is III and d2 but none of the
squares are that good Queen to d2 was
played and now comes King to b8 Quinta
g3 seems like a reasonable idea but
Vincent sees that his position is
excellent and first he improves it even
more so King to be 8 and now rooks e2 e1
preparing it to push the pawn or to open
up the file so pawn captures 94f
captures on e4 and now Bishop to d7 rook
to f2 rook to e8 and now Queen to a4
check King moves to a a 8 now comes
Knight to f3 and rook to f8 now
attacking the Queen Queen has to go all
the way to h2 and now Knight to a4 and
this Knight to a4 is a powerful move
that that really locks in the position
for black it's threatening to win the c3
pawn if the c3 pawn is the gand and then
white is simply lost the only thing
white really has for this piece is this
strong center another thing the knight
on e4 does it doesn't allow doubling of
the rooks on the B file you can always
go up to be one but you can never go
wrong to be 2 so it definitely an
excellent piece and it will be used in a
in a combination later on so rook to e3
defending the c3 pawn and now a six
still not rushing anything
Vincent simply improves his position
making room for the King so no back rank
ideas can happen in the future and here
it's it's extremely hard to find a move
for white you can't really push ePHI you
would like to push ePHI v6e 7 but if you
push e 5 then this night is coming to b6
you're you're allowing
this night an excellent square on d5 and
although the night is annoying on a4 it
would be even more annoying on d5 and
another thing you're allowing this
bishop to come to c6 it will be
extremely an extremely powerful piece
another thing aside from e5 you don't
really have a move here if you try
something like rook F to e - - maybe -
maybe Riemann over the rooks then after
black makes a move Queen g6 you could
maybe play rook to e1 maybe go for the
go for the be one file or g1 then the
night is coming to be - and then after
this night comes to d3 it will be a
great position for black so all of this
in mind and probably low on time a
rapper plays Queen to e5 but Queen to e5
is now definitely a move that allows
black to finish the game nicely Bishop
captures on h3 so what you do here
Robert played King did you want and King
did you want is the strongest move if
you capture the bishop then you get a
row captures on h3 this comes with check
you have to block rook to h2 and now
rock to g3 wins the game
there's the terrible thread of rook
captors on f3 followed by a rook to g1
checkmate
you'd have to block this Queen to d5
attacking blacks Queen but black will
simply get the Queen out of the attack
the threat is still there and after
white makes a move you will simply win
the game now Rakesh three check captures
captures King g1 Queen to g3 check and
now you win a piece with check and it's
all over so a Bishop captures an h3
excellent move definitely a win a
winning move King to g1 of course you
can't capture it and now rope to g7 with
a triple triple threat on g2 nice to H
for defending but rook captures on f2
King captures on f2 you removed one of
the defenders of the g2 pawn rook
captures Knight captures and Queen
captures Angie - so now black does have
two pieces for the rook but it's it's
it's completely winning game King te one
here Queen to f1 was played King to d2
and now Bishop to g4 here Vincent is
threatening Queen to d1 checkmate and
black a white doesn't have a movie
if you try something like rope to g3
maybe make room for King John III to
escape it doesn't really work queen to
have to check King moves and now comes
check this out
Queen to be to checkmate look at this
night on a for protecting this Queen the
bishop is guarding hun d1 square it's a
very nice checkmate you know I haven't
seen a Dark Knight this useful on a4
since Bobby Fischer's a game of the
century probably so after Bishop to g4
rapper tried one more idea to play Queen
to 8th check King moves and now Queen
captures on a4 now the Queen from a4 is
guarding the d1 square but here Queen to
f2 was played by Vincent and it was in
this position and move 51 that Richard
the report resigned the game what would
follow of course if you block with the
rock queen simply captures and if you
move the King simply again Queen
captures and okay you do have you still
do have your strong center for for
blacks Bishop but after b5 and you move
the Queen before simply shatters white
center and there's really nothing to do
here for white this comes with check
white would win this game very a black
would win this game very easily so yeah
after this I mean have to check a rapper
to resign the game and a brilliant
victory for thirteen-year-old
International Master Vincent came are
from Germany and especially winning
winning a tournament of this magnitude
with almost 800 players like I said is
unimaginable especially with a game like
this this is this is a spectacular game
with the black pieces against a monster
like a Richard Report and I did prepare
for you a list of all of the all of the
players he faced so this is a from round
1 to round 9 these are all the players
he faced so as you can see ok maybe some
of maybe be only there I mean ok his
first opponent was rated 2087 his second
2200 but then you have 2660 21 48 2500
and 320 510 twenty five hundred and
eighty eight twenty six hundred and four
and lastly in this game richard report
twenty seven hundred and fifteen so out
of the nine players he faced five of
them were grandmasters and out of those
the five grandmasters he hasn't lost a
single game so ro nine games seven wins
and two draws this is this is simply
incredible
and so with eight points ro 9 he's the
he's the sole winner in first place I
believe there were three players with
seven and a half points out of nine so
I'm done core above being one of them
and I think Antone horrible
I just recently also had like half a
point less than even cherish in the
European individual championship so I'm
comfortable an amazing player always you
know always in there at the top almost
winning it but I'm sure he will start
winning it very soon and I believe
Alexey Shiro also had seven and a half
out of nine and one more player but I
really can't remember who it was but
yeah Winston Kaymer and the the quote
above the board
Peter Lake was saying even Magnus would
be happy with a dotter nine app it'll
echo is the official commentator of the
cranky chest classic with young
Gustafson and he's actually the coach of
young Vincent Kaymer so he was extremely
happy he won this and now he will he
will start coaching him and preparing
him for for next year
and when he will be participating in the
ranked HS classic where he will probably
face Magnus Carlsen and all the other
great beasts of chess so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it you know
feel free to congratulate Vincent gamer
using any any means possible as this is
this is an incredible result for for
such a young player you know I'm not
gonna say it's like one Bobby Fischer
won won the USA championship as there
were some impressive players there but
you know it's you know almost but maybe
maybe even so so yeah I would like to
thank a Joseph Preston and Amedeo see
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank over
and I will see you soon with another
interesting game thank you